hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
III is fast approaching and as every
self-respecting video gamer knows it's
the place to be to climb on Bob the hype
train and to plan out future purchases
I've trolled through all the rumors and
speculation to find 15 games to look
forward to at e3 2018 so if you're ready
let's do this let's start with the one I
can't pronounce ghosts of Tsushima
first teased a year ago is now time to
see some early game play set in 1274 and
based in Japan around their legendary
samurai defenders during the Mongol
invasion we play as one of the last
remaining samurai that invasion by the
Mongol Empire was a very real historic
event so play with the knowledge that
you're learning about history as you
slay thousands of enemies this will be
another open-world game with RPG
elements supporting both stealth and
action play styles the developers behind
ghosts of Tsushima are the much-loved
sucker-punch team who previously made
Sly Cooper and the infamous series
speaking of Japan did you ever play the
tenchu stealth assassin games they had
an awesome blend of tactical play
stealth kills and one-on-one combat
sadly as time went by the follow-up
games didn't live up to expectations and
we all forgot about Ricky Maru a few
months ago the series developer from
software teased a new project in a
30-second clip we only see this
blood-soaked
object and the words shadows die twice
this could be a brand spanking new IP or
it could be a return to tenchu as Ricky
Maru lives in the shadows and look to
have died in one of the game
one of the characters even says shadows
die twice word-for-word in the game
surely that's not a coincidence the best
thing about this is if I'm wrong the
worst case scenario we'll see
blood-borne two announced instead it's a
win-win for gamers you either live with
the choices you make
or die trying to change them
anthems sprang unto the stage at last
year's e3 and stole the show a shared
world action RPG where you and your
friends held these javelin mech suits
it's another perpetual world which is
designed to bring people in and play for
years much like destiny and the division
over the past 12 months the shine has
dulled somewhat with problems at the dev
studio including key departures plus the
loot box issues that plagued many titles
has been a focal point here for many
gamers anthem will be back bigger and
better than ever at e3 2018 let's hope
it's not too late for this one because
it has so much potential
let's look at another shared world
shooter the division - did you play the
first one the premise saw an elite group
attempt to bring justice an order to the
streets of New York after a smallpox
pandemic hit the city the cover shooting
and general mechanics were great but the
game fell flat for many people after the
story wrapped up the developers have
continued to this day to improve the
division and are now ready to try again
with another title will we see a new
city maybe a different country will we
see a completely different approach III
should give us answers to those
questions cyberpunk 2077 was first
teased 5 years ago
the title has taken so long that many
people believe it may be heading to PS 5
rather than current gen hardware but
what many people are missing is that the
game is made by CD Projekt RED the
masterminds behind the witcher series if
you've ever played witcher 3 wild hunt
you know the size and detail you can
expect from cyberpunk 2077 the game
itself is set in 2077 as the world
reached the pinnacle of artificial
intelligence mega corporations now rule
the world after the fall of governments
and you will exist within this setting
this will be an expansive role-playing
game with countless quest to uncover III
2018 has been confirmed to see the
reveal of more details and the hype
train should explode once again a game
which is almost upon us already is
Marvel's spider-man releasing on
September the 7th we've slowly seen more
information about the game including
characters and costumes and even a
collector's edition to pre-order this
year at e3 expect Sony to double down on
Spidey and give us new gameplay from new
locations and hopefully more villains
uncovered - maybe the city needs our
friend what do you think
will I become
shadow of the Tomb Raider is another
game releasing in September
one week after spider-man in fact this
one picks up straight after the events
of rise of the Tomb Raider and sees Lara
Croft's expedition to Latin America
searching for yet another MacGuffin for
her trophy cabinet expect a supernatural
theme to run through this one as Lara
once again saves the world from
impending Armageddon did you play the
first one what did you think - it oh my
word there are so many games dropping in
September and October probably the
biggest game of the year Red Dead
Redemption 2 is set to release on
October the 18th you already know about
Red Dead but just in case you've been
living under a rock Red Dead 2 is a
prequel to the Wild West
action-adventure story of John Marston
we'll be joining his criminal gang led
by Dutch van der Linde and living the
unlawful life over the past eight months
Rockstar have given us trailers to whet
our appetites and although everything is
looking damn good we still haven't seen
any real gameplay expect that to change
at e3 one of Playstations biggest titles
The Last of Us part 2 is booked in to
have a huge presence at e3 the actors
have booked their hotels and Sony have
confirmed the game will be showcased
we'll be following Joel and Ellie once
again following the events of the first
game in which a zombie epidemic has
crushed humanity and the two looked for
a cure but what will happen next game
director Neil druckmann has said the
Last of Us part two we'll focus on
revenge it looks like Ellie is going on
the warpath after she finishes playing
this song
I got a granddaughter who likes dressing
up - she loves Peter Pan shawl was
asking this old timer to read it to her
The Walking Dead has had many video
games made in its honor
clementines journey in the telltale
version remains a highlight well now a
four person cooperative shooter from the
makers of payday 2 is on the way over
kills that the Walking Dead have began
to show vignettes of characters which
demonstrates the vicious and dark nature
of the game also one of the characters
looks like a lo from horizon zero dawn
yeah this here III 2018 will hopefully
see in-game footage instead of the
cinematic trailers we've seen so far
fingers crossed this one looks very
promising psvr seems to be taking a
backseat at the moment even though there
are literally over 100 games being
released in this year alone upcoming
title blood and truth puts you inside
the gritty and glamorous London gangster
underworld if you played London heist on
the PSP our worlds demo you'll know
exactly what to expect
abusive banter explosions galore and
fast-paced gameplay additionally it will
be possible to change the story during
certain sections of the game such as
interrogating a suspect or just shooting
them in the face I got out of me I'm
really hyped for this one please be good
blood and true yo stop talking
listen it was all his idea
Linda how are you doing
your nothing good real good the Metal
Gear Solid franchise looks to be over
after Hideo Kojima left Konami and the
underwhelming reception of Metal Gear
survived this is left a hole in the
shape of a stealth and tactical
espionage hero to fill the perfect
person to fill this void is Sam Fisher
and the Splinter Cell franchise recently
Sam voiced by Michael Ironside cameoed
in Ghost Recon wildlands even saluting
Solid Snake for his impact on the world
now looks to be the perfect time to
bring back Splinter Cell and attract all
those disillusioned mgs players what do
you think would you play another
splinter cell game once there was an
explosion a bang which gave rise to life
as we know it we've already mentioned
Hideo Kojima leaving Konami so let's
talk about his next game death stranding
where to begin with this one described
as a quasi action game set in an open
world it's going to include new
never-used gaming mechanics in other
words death stranding is trying to push
barriers and cover new ground the whole
project is shrouded in so much secrecy
and intricacies that no one has a clue
what's going on from invisible monsters
to babies in jars we have to find out
more at e3
another action RPG set to be covered at
e3 is Kingdom Hearts 3 if like me you're
new to the series it's essentially an
RPG mashup including Disney characters
like Donald Duck and Mickey Mouse and
Final Fantasy mainstays such as Sora and
Riku some of the settings come straight
out of Disney's movies and many voice
actors return to represent their
respective franchises the series has a
cult following which grows every single
year
I've never played the Kingdom Hearts
game have you would you recommend it and
finally here's one I just have to throw
in every year I get hyped for one game
in particular Borderlands 3 and every
year I'm let down but this year I'm
almost certain it will arrive mainly due
to a leak by Walmart Borderlands was the
innovator of randomized loot and
cel-shaded graphics and made two great
games and one less inspiring pre sequel
which derailed the franchise somewhat
but I digress the over-the-top
characters the ridiculous weapons the
maniacal bosses
come on gearbox make this the year for
Borderlands 3 please I beg you there's
no chance isn't enough there's no chance
so there we have it 15 games to be
excited about during e3 2018 what floats
your boat and what have I missed for me
it has to be the Gulf of Tsushima who
doesn't want to play as a samurai I'm
also keeping an eye on cyberpunk 2077
that game could be humongous as always
my opinion means diddly-squat what are
you saving your cash for and by the way
if you want to talk to me either hit me
up on Twitter or comment below starting
it with Adam aru and I will endeavor to
reply to as many as I can I'm Adam from
PlayStation granade it's been a damn
pleasure I'll see you next
[Music]
you
[Music]